long Wing life spent six months in a
Hong Kong prison for taking part in an
unauthorized demonstration in 2014.
it was there Hong Kong's 90 year old
former Bishop Cardinal Joseph Zen came
to meet him and other inmates
it took him at least three hours to
travel there which is so physically
demanding for an elderly person I'm so
grateful that he came all that way just
to visit us now the Cardinal is on his
mind once again as he faces a challenge
of his own he and five co-defendants are
accused of failing to register a fund to
support those arrested during the 2019
protests they have pleaded not guilty
the prosecution says the fund raised
more than 34.4 million dollars and was
used for political activities and
non-charity events but the defense
argues the right to form an association
is guaranteed under Hong Kong's basic
law
while the penalty is likely to be only a
fine legal expert say they are worried
there's a concern that's been raised
that you know the process of going
through this that the government is
trying to get more
materials and more information to
possibly then charge them under the more
serious offenses
Reverend Tobias brandner says he would
often see Cardinal Zen on Prison visits
and describes him as someone who tried
to comfort those in need his social
justice role is maybe well known but
there is also very much his role as a
very humble servant of God
during his career Cardinal Zen has been
a staunch critic of Beijing he openly
opposed plans to allow Beijing to
jointly appoint Bishops with the Vatican
what they know about
the quality is required to be a bishop
and this week that agreement was renewed
more than 1.2 million Christians live in
Hong Kong some pro-beijing lawmakers in
the territory say the trial has nothing
to do with religious freedom
verdict is expected in November Jessica
Washington Al Jazeera Hong Kong